a revolution in Dragon Ball games the
legendary warrior says you've never seen
the before relive every planet
shattering moment of these famous
battles it's a whole new adventure
[ __ ] slop cometh deep
a sudden crisis gripped the universe
blue day honey on atomic psyche david
icke's - ah it's nothing I thought this
material of this the dragonballs are in
grave peril
the gods are control time are battling
to regain control dude your power will
be what saves the world of Dragon Ball
Dragon Ball xenoverse anyone can be a
Saiyan anyone can be Goku
anyone can be a sipper warrior special
beam cannon solar flare Destructo dips
classic moves all launching from your
fingers you're coming on a huh might
just see the Dragon Ball world the hero
is go to know the hero is you
someone sinister is disrupting the
timeline erasing Goku and his companions
battle from history
in desperation Trump summons you into
the world to right this wrong is a time
patrol warrior inserting yourself into
the world of Dragon Balls and restoring
the lost history of battle you will need
to prepare for all kinds of battles in
all kinds of situations one-on-one
battles massive group battles the
possibilities are endless and then the
Warriors assemble a gathering spot for
all game activities the largest online
world in Dragonball history tell its
other players to duels or invite them to
go on an adventure
enlist the original anime characters as
your personal trainers then master their
skills and moves even get access to
their costumes rich customization
options choose from over 450 unique
decorations and over 200 special moves
recreate yourself or reinvent yourself
be the strongest you can be join hands
with your fellow warriors and learn new
ways to communicate across time and
space dive into the adventure
one that spans all eternity through
adventuring training you will one day
stand victorious
can you bring back the Dragonball
timeline and restore those epic battles
to the legends of history and take back
the Dragonball World Dragonball
xenoverse stay tuned for more details